Ron Howard grew up in front of America's
eyes first is the young Opie Taylor on
The Andy Griffith Show and then as
Richie Cunningham on happy days before
jumping behind the camera to become one
of Hollywood's most prolific directors
over the past 40 years the Oscar winner
has held big films including splash
cocoon Apollo 13 a beautiful mind and
most recently solo a Star Wars story and
today he's here to tell us about his
latest project
national Geographics critically
acclaimed series Mars
season two premieres a week from Monday
here's a peek and Jim should have been
completed yesterday which is it a month
you can only make four fell in as fast
as we can make it it's gonna be fine
Mike there's one thing worse teaches you
it's patience
looks like they're here it's not like
anyone could stop them from coming this
was 7 good of these
[Applause]
and Ron Howard is here good morning we
are so excited I know I've been watched
all of season one started season two
cool I really like the approach to your
storytelling you call it a hybrid yes
well thank you you know it Brian Grazer
and I fell in love with the idea of
doing Mars it was brought to us by
radical media we've done some other
projects with them and NatGeo was
interested that was exciting we started
interviewing a lot of a lot of great
experts and and you could first of all
they were fascinating yeah including you
on musk who would give us access to you
know do research and so forth that
SpaceX but we saw that's exciting so
then the thought was well let's do a
documentary about what everybody is
doing to go to Mars because it turned
out to be way more involved and many
many more brilliant people dedicated to
that idea than we ever realized but we
also wanted the cinema we wanted the
drama we want to be in the adventure so
our thinking shifted from totally
scripted totally doc and then wait a
minute yeah so Brian actually got this
idea let's do it as a hybrid took it to
Courtney Monroe at NatGeo
they went for it and it was a total
experiment and yet we learned so much in
season one and I was proud of season one
people are catching up with it all the
time and I think it's great but season
two we have so much more confidence
about the storytelling style and it
really shows in the episode it does it
works so well and people that haven't
seen it it really is you'll go from this
scripted drama into what's present day
or a real news clip and then into these
interviews does one leave the other or
like do you find the things to fit with
the drama or do you have the you don't
have thing in season one we more let the
experts lead us okay we were learning
about what it's going to take to go to
Mars what would be like to be there and
we were building scenes around that
going into season two we first of all
we'd already done a lot of that research
we already knew what we were looking for
with this this goes years later when it
started it's the beginning of it of a
community and it's this clash now
between science
and Industry yes because now it's it's
time to mine Mars at least one group
feels that that's that's a vitally
important so the reality is that in the
second season we knew what we were
looking for we knew what the stories
were we still went out and discovered a
lot of information yeah you know about
we focus been a lot of time in
Antarctica this is not just all Talking
Heads the documentary portion is very
cinematic as well yeah and I think I
think cinematic is kind of the word that
we keep applying to the series because
we want to make sure that that it is
like a movie that it transports you
right and the but it's not it's science
fiction sure nobody's gone there yet and
yet there's so much authority behind the
ideas because you have these experts
explaining what it's gonna be like would
you by the way would you ever have any
interest in going into space if they
needed a director I'm not the most
adventurous in person are you surprised
at how much of your cinematic drama
really speaks to today and our politics
well I mean as you start delving into
these subjects you you begin to find
parallels and and and of course you
begin building a new society a human
culture on another planet it just
immediately begs those kind of questions
like what what you know what are some of
those same battle lines or or
controversies they're not even battle
lines although things do get a little
heated up there your list of films and
Michelle mentioned some of them it is a
legacy on its own but you also became a
part of the Star Wars legacy yeah what
is it like for you to take on a task
like that well it's you know I've been
around it because you know I acted for
George Lucas on American Graffiti yeah
and and you know when I asked him what
his next film was gonna be he described
this crazy thing it was sort of like a
Flash Gordon but it wasn't Flash Gordon
and sort of like 2001 Space Odyssey but
it wasn't 2000 and I it sounded like
kind of a mess to me when I went to see
you that movie you know I was
transported as was everyone so when I
came into that situation for solo it was
really a thrill because
there is so much passion behind those
movies there's nothing you went into it
I thought well I wonder if this is a
little bit like a television series
where they kind of know what how they
what they want and they just sort of
crank it out not at all you know and led
by Kathy Kennedy that group is so
focused on I'm just trying to do trying
to do great work one one last thing we
talked about this you were in two iconic
television series and then and made it
turn into directing your first film was
Grand Theft Auto in 77 you said yes and
you have you always wanted to be a
director I from the time I was a little
kid I had observed my dad directing
theater and he also ran a little improv
workshop out of our house my father
Rance Howard who passed away last year
but but was loved it loved the business
loved writing and and and directed a lot
of theater also a lot of the almost all
of the directors on The Andy Griffith
Show had been an actor he and I became
fascinated by the whole process and they
saw that and from the time I was about
eight years old nine years old I
remember them saying I thought you're
gonna wind up being a director so I
think this was something in the back of
my mind then the 60s came along and
movies were like there was this whole
revolution and you know it's starting
with the graduate and Zeffirelli's Romeo
and Juliet and Bonnie and Clyde and I
fell in love with the medium of movies
and I realized it was quite different
from what we were doing on our
television show and that's when I became
a fan and so having grown up in it and
then falling in love with the medium it
became my total obsession we are so glad
actually matter Ron Howard for leaving
happy days this series is called Mars
and season two premieres Monday November
12th on National Geographic Ron Howard
thank you again fragment in time to talk
to y'all